this video is made possible by nordvpn
you know the stories you read about
people having their data stolen well
they really do happen
and that is where nordvpn comes in
but using a vpn offers more than just
security for example nordvpn lets you
access any of its thousands of servers
in different countries
all around the globe so that means your
content availability isn't limited to
your geographic location for example
most european countries have strong
licensing agreements restricting which
soccer matches can be viewed depending
on the location of the viewer with
northvpn you can change your country
without ever moving from your sofa
nordvpn is super fast so watching video
is a breeze no lag whatsoever if you've
ever used vpns and you thought they were
slow
no more with nordvpn and you can use it
on all your devices
very very easily android chrome windows
linux and on up to six different devices
on one account
also there are no logs kept at all
unlike other companies based in the eu
or the us
nordvpn is based in panama so they don't
have to keep logs at
all which is great for your privacy so
take control of your internet experience
right now with nordvpn
get a huge discount on a two-year plan
of nordvpn at nordvpn.com
visualpolitik and when you use our code
visualpolitik you'll get an additional
bonus for free it's risk-free with
nord's 30-day money-back guarantee
now let's get cracking
[Music]
at long last after much tooing and
throwing
brexit became a reality once and for all
a project
a mission a desire that seemed as
improbable as it was far-fetched is now
a fact
since the beginning of 2021 the united
kingdom has been walking alone
along the tricky paths of the world's
political and economic agenda the
world's once dominant power now faces
a new uncertain and challenging future
to give you an idea the european
commission has estimated that brexit
will cost the british
economy more than 40 billion pounds per
year that's about
56 billion us dollars for its part the
uk's own office for budget
responsibility points to a fallen
productivity of almost four percent
and increased inflation levels the
reasons behind all these forecasts have
to do with the united kingdom's exit
from the european economic commercial
and political integration project
[Music]
although the trade agreement reached
between the united kingdom and the
european union at the end of 2020
abolish the possibility of establishing
trade tariffs it did not curb the
customs procedures that hinder trade in
other words
british businessmen and women now face a
lot of paperwork inspections and red
tape of all kinds and their trade flows
to the old continent we're talking about
things like
health checks security checks and
customs tax clearance
[Music]
and take note because this is not a
trivial matter every year the united
kingdom exports some 400 billion dollars
worth of goods
and services to the european union in
this vein a make uk survey found that
nearly three quarters of companies have
experienced delays and moving goods
into the european union in recent months
even the lucrative financial industry in
the city of london has taken a hit
in fact amsterdam has already displaced
london as the leading market for
european company shares
amsterdam ousts london as europe's top
share trading hub
uk's departure from the eu prompts shift
in dealing of stocks and derivatives
financial times
now wait a minute does all this mean
that brexit is a fundamentally bad idea
that it is doomed to inevitably
impoverish the british people where
exactly does the uk stand and what
approach do they have in downing street
to deal with the situation today
and perhaps the most important question
of all are we on the verge
of the rebirth of british preeminence or
on the verge of its final decline to
answer that question today you're gonna
have to listen up
[Music]
is it true that all the roads look bad
[Applause]
on this occasion i am not going to tell
you about the relative success the
united kingdom has had with respect to
the european union in managing
vaccination against covert 19.
what interests us in this video is
looking ahead and the first question we
need to answer and to be clear about is
exactly what role does the uk play
in the global economy okay i know i'm
sure you're all familiar with the
influence of the city of london and the
british financial industry we are
talking about one of the two great
capitals of world finance
to give you an idea financial services
alone contributes almost
200 billion dollars to the uk's gdp more
than 11
of all listed companies in the world are
listed on the london stock exchange but
wait a minute because that is far from
their only strength as surprising as it
may seem
and a fact that often goes unnoticed as
the united kingdom remains one of the
world's
major economies we are talking about the
fifth largest economy
in the world behind only the united
states china japan
and germany it also happens to be the
fifth largest exporter of goods
and services
[Music]
and that is not all the truth is that
the bulk of foreign direct investment
that is for example what is invested in
factories real estate and in companies
is much greater in the british economy
than in cases such as germany or france
in addition the united kingdom ranks
fourth in the global innovation ranking
it is the third largest global
destination for technology investment
and
is also the country that ranks third in
the world for having the highest number
of
unicorns
yes that's right it's often overlooked
but the uk is not only a financial
powerhouse it is also a technological
powerhouse
especially when compared to the rest of
europe for example the uk builds more
satellites and attracts more digital
investment than any other european
country
[Music]
but it is not just about economic clout
from a security point of view the united
kingdom has the second largest military
budget in nato and the largest in europe
it has the greatest capacity to operate
globally in the old continent and
its intelligence agencies rank at the
top of the world which anyone
like me is a james bond fan would know
and then there is what is known
as soft power this country is the second
favorite destination for foreign
students
after the united states in fact one in
four countries worldwide has a head of
state or government who studied
in the uk
one in four that my friends is called
influence plain and simple and that's
without mentioning the global reach of
the premier league the bbc
british schools and brit pop though i
would like to take this opportunity to
apologize for everyone
in britain for oasis
in other words whichever way you look at
it the united kingdom remains one of the
most
important and influential countries on
the planet what's more the british want
to remain high
on the international agenda however it
is now clear that their situation has
changed being outside the european union
means having to rebuild foreign policy
trade policy and even security policy
all on its own
having left the european union united
kingdom has begun a new chapter in our
history we are open to the world
boris johnson so what we are about to
see is the approach
the strategy the policy with which the
british government wants to optimize
and consolidate its role in the world
this is the recipe the formula with
which they hope to overcome brexit
and europe check this out
[Music]
the conquest of the east
in addition to the trade and cooperation
agreement signed with the european union
to avoid the dreaded tariffs between
early 2019 and 2021 the british
government had already signed trade
agreements with 66 countries outside the
european union
the target set by downing street is that
by the end of 2023 the country should
have trade agreements in place with
countries accounting for at least
80 percent of britain's trade for the
time being a new global tariff system
has already been established for those
imports that are not covered by a trade
agreement that is simpler and
lower than that of the eu
in total as of the 1st of january 2021
almost 60 percent of trade will enter
the country duty-free with the remaining
at rates below the international average
convention not a bad start however
today the great british gamble is on
three main playing fields
the united states the kansas area and
above all the reconquest
of the orient let's start at the
beginning
the united states is the largest trading
partner and the largest investor
in the country for this reason one of
the absolute priorities that london has
set itself is to achieve a free trade
agreement with this great american power
this could reinforce the uk's role as
the natural point of connection between
the u.s and the european union while
improving access for british companies
to a market worth
millions to billions of dollars
[Music]
and this is something that seems much
easier to achieve than a free trade
agreement between the united states and
the european union directly in other
words here brexit could provide a clear
distinct
advantage then on the other hand as we
have covered in past videos the idea of
strengthening the kansas union the
country's economic integration with
canada australia and new zealand has
gained a lot of momentum in london the
relationship with these three countries
is very good
at all levels and although it may be a
smaller club together they account for
seven percent of the global economy
but above all perhaps the most
disruptive aspect for the johnson
administration's new economic and trade
policy is its firm commitment to
reconquer
the east which is a sentence that will
make a lot of british ex-colonies
very nervous
[Music]
but downing street is clear the
indo-pacific is the engine of global
growth
half of the population 40 of global gdp
and
the highest economic growth rates are
located in what was historically
considered the east we're talking about
countries such as japan
china india indonesia vietnam south
korea
take note trade between the uk and india
more than doubled between 2007 and 2019
and by early 2021 the two countries had
signed an enhanced trade partnership an
agreement with which they hope to double
mutual trade again
by 2030 and which also opens the door to
a future free trade agreement
by the way this is something we
discussed in the weekly snapshot a
bulletin that we send out every week to
all our patrons
if you feel like supporting us follow
the link in the description anyway the
fact is that london considers the indian
market to be
absolutely key the two countries have
close historical
social and economic ties is a polite way
of putting it and if the indian economy
finally takes off that could be a
huge boost for the british economy but
perhaps the most daring and surprising
move has been the request to join the
cptp the descendant agreement to the tpp
the trans-pacific agreement that trump
tore up as soon as he arrived in the
white house
of course the rest of the countries went
ahead without the american power
creating a market of 500 million people
and around 14
of the world's gdp we're talking about
japan australia vietnam singapore canada
mexico malaysia brunei new zealand and
peru
it seems that south korea and thailand
as well as the united kingdom could soon
join this agreement but
let's see why on earth would the uk want
to join a trans-pacific trade agreement
what advantage could there be in linking
up with such far away countries
well look
[Music]
beyond access to 500 million consumers
joining this agreement would bring the
united kingdom into the diplomatic
framework
and above all very importantly into the
regulatory framework as for example in
terms of services and the digital
environment two of the strengths of the
british economy in other words by
entering into this type of agreement the
united kingdom will be able to adapt
more easily and also
contribute to the development of the
regulatory framework of some of the
markets and with the greatest economic
potential
in the world
and so it is in this way looking
directly to the united states the kansas
group and above all else
to the east the boris johnson's british
government wants to make the united
kingdom the benchmark european operator
in world trade
this is the big gamble that the british
government has in play and one with
which they hope to make brexit
profitable they also assume that most of
the difficulties that have arisen and
trade with the european union will
gradually be ironed out or
just disappear and that therefore the
cost of the exit will be progressively
reduced but johnson's project is not
limited exclusively to the commercial
field if we are talking about aspiring
to maintain a powerful role in the world
then we must also talk about what is
happening
in the military field and that is
something the british government has not
forgotten check this out
the return of the royal navy
was a time when the royal navy was
master of the world's
seas the spearhead the indispensable
element the greatest reference of the
greatest empire the world has ever
known however these days that is
something for the history books
the truth is is the last two decades
have not exactly been great
for the british armed forces especially
for the royal navy
the loss of a large part of its
amphibious capabilities naval aircraft
and a good number of ships led to an
unprecedented decline for example while
in 1991 the british navy had 34 frigates
and 17 more in various stages of
production by 2020
it had 13.
the situation was such that in 2010 the
government withdrew the navy's harriers
from service thus remaining without a
carrier-based aircraft and in 2018 faced
with a lack of budget they sold hms
ocean one of the most important
amphibious deployment ships to brazil
however the situation may now be
completely different the arrival of the
new queen elizabeth class aircraft
carriers new f-35 ship-borne fighters
the construction of new frigates new
astute attack submarines
and new plans for strategic submarines
the successor project the most expensive
military program in the history of the
united kingdom seem to show the return
of the golden era of the royal navy but
what has changed above all
is the political will protecting our
people
our homeland and our democracy is the
first duty of any government which is
why i have begun the biggest defense
investment program since the end of the
cold war this will show
our allies in europe and beyond that
they can always count on the uk
when it really matters boris johnson the
government has announced a substantial
increase in military spending
and a new plan for additional investment
and modernisation of the armed forces of
more than 34 billion dollars over the
next four years
in addition to those already underway in
total we are talking about a figure that
could exceed
50 billion in four or five years it
represents
by far the largest investment in the
armed forces since the end of the cold
war in addition a large part of this
figure will go to high-tech programs and
also the creation of a new cyber force
and a new space command the british
government has even decided to break
with its nuclear policy in 2010 they
announced a shock reduction in their
nuclear weapons arsenals they have now
taken the opposite direction the uk will
increase its nuclear weapons arsenal to
260 warheads 80 more than the previous
target after all who doesn't love
nuclear warheads but that is not all
to boost its international presence the
british government is not only betting
on keeping one of its new aircraft
carriers deployed for a long time
in southeast asia or increasing the
number of troops stationed aboard but
for example to improve their operability
with those of allied countries such as
australia it is also studying the
possibility of opening new military
bases abroad there is speculation about
the possibility of establishing new
permanent military bases in singapore
and brunei this will be in addition to
the facilities it already has in bahrain
diego garcia or belize
the idea is for the united kingdom to
remain not only a priority ally of the
united states but also
a decisive country thanks to its
deployment and deterrence capabilities
in other words for the united kingdom to
once again
become a globally recognized power and a
commercial
financial and military model so in a way
this is the flip side of brexit of
course
it remains to be seen whether the
government will get its way there are
certainly
many challenges ahead it is not that
easy we will definitely be talking about
this
in the future but now it's over to you
what do you think the future holds for
the uk do you think boris johnson's
plans will come to fruition when will we
see the royal navy controlling the world
sees again
and just how nervous should that make
other countries leave your answer in the
comments and if you found this video
interesting don't forget to subscribe
and
like visualpolitik and remember that you
can get a huge discount on a two-year
plan of nordvpn at nordvpn.com
visualpolitik and when you use our code
visualpolitik you'll get an additional
bonus for free it's
risk-free with nord's 30-day money-back
guarantee tally how old boys
i'll see you next time